una enorme nube de polvo se eleva por el
cielo mientras otro sector de silos del
puerto de aveiro se derrumba las torres
habían estado inclinándose lentamente
durante días antes de que finalmente se
dieran tras un derrumbe parcial el
domingo los expertos habían advertido
que más trozos de los hilos corrían
peligro de caer en pedazos para los
residentes ver el humo saliendo de este
lugar es como revivir el trauma de la
explosión
cuando vi el humo sentí como si volviera
a vivir la explosión me asusté pero al
mismo tiempo me hice a la idea de que
podía ocurrir otra explosión
y el fijarte en
la ruptura se produjo una hora antes de
que cientos de personas iniciarán su
marcha hacia el puerto para conmemorar
el segundo aniversario de la catástrofe
los cielos de 50 años de antigüedad
habían resistido a la fuerza de la
explosión de 2020 que destruyó gran
parte del puerto uno de los incidentes
más destructivos de la historia moderna
del líbano la demolición de los silos
prevista inicialmente se suspendió ya
que muchos de los familiares de las
víctimas exigieron que se mantuviera
como monumento conmemorativo la tragedia
provocada por la detonación de una
enorme reserva de nitrato de amonio
atribuye en gran medida la corrupción y
mala gestión del gobierno dos años
después los intentos de hacer rendir
cuentas a los responsables siguen en un
estancamiento político